all right guys you're ready to head to
Portugal and Spain on a great trip and
Adventure yeah
yeah that's the doctor's office
let go we're taking you you're going to
the doctor's office come on
did you survive yes you want to go to
Portugal now yeah
[Music]
or take me far away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're in the capital city of
Lisbon
[Music]
and uh we gotta go get checked into our
rental property I gotta figure out how
to drive this thing what is that is that
that he got strive there's no USB ports
in this car they're all usbcs
wait did they drive on the left to the
right side here Becca right right side
oh good
job
that's what I think all right come check
it out here we go mama
oh look at this bunk beds in here guys
yeah
oh that's slick
oh my God
oh watch your head
look at this this is nice I could just
sit here and listen to audiobooks yeah
is this a cool houseboat yeah I wish we
well we thought this would be kind of a
fun novelty to get a houseboat in
downtown Lisbon it was actually pretty
affordable
listen would you guys like to go do a
little tour of Lisbon you really
we're on a red light and there's a guy
twirling a flaming baton in the
intersection in front of us I do not
know if this is normal in Portugal
oh that's a cool statue
all right guys we're in downtown Lisbon
and we're gonna go with Teo tucktuck
tours and we're gonna do a little
tuk-tuck ride around Lisbon all right
I'll stand next to you oh I'm so glad to
have a professional driving instead of
me what do you guys think is this cool
yeah
this is the this is the egg cart place
yes oh
food is a priority with us so we're
gonna get some Portuguese egg Tarts here
which is a traditional sweet Portuguese
pastry oh this place is cool
yeah look at the muffins are on the tray
and they go around
and they get dropped over there
okay we ordered like a ton of these as
always I'll put a link to this place and
all the other cool things we do in the
video description below all right we got
our food
it's like nice egg cup when we were in
Hong Kong for breakfast every morning
we'd get up and buy egg Tarts and dragon
fruit oh it was so good oh yeah that's a
nice one oh nice Becca are these better
than the ones in Hong Kong yeah it's
like a puff pastry crust and creme
brulee got together and had a baby it
just oh this good I think that was worth
the flight just for the egg tart yeah is
this a great way to eat dinner
so that's that's an elevator yeah go for
the 45 liters to the top
IC
so right now we're just driving through
the old part of Lisbon apparently this
is the second oldest neighborhood in
Europe it was built in the 10th Century
we're seeing a lot of quaint little
streets and cool cathedrals
yes all right big you want to share a
croquette with me
it's fried mashed potatoes with meats
and veggies inside oh that's like a veal
a veal croquette check it out guys this
is the remains of a Roman Theater they
were trying to restore a building that
was destroyed during an earthquake in
the 70s and they found the remains of
this giant Roman Theater here that's
where they would do the Gladiator fights
and they would have people fight animals
like lions and stuff 4 000 people would
come here and watch
from the 13th century we're driving
through these beautiful neighborhoods
with these old houses that have these
hand-painted tile facades just
absolutely gorgeous and with this we had
to run into a cafe to use the bathroom
and I bought these brigaderos yeah
it's delicious I don't know what it is
but it's really soft
this is a part of Lisbon where they have
a lot of traditional restaurants and
photo music it's kind of like a
beautiful sad folk music
fantasy
hey thanks thank you we had a great time
do you enjoy that yeah yeah that was
really cool and a great activity after a
long day of traveling
all right you all tucked in all right
we'll get you to bed
let me see
hey good morning guys
you guys sleep well yeah look we got a
picnic basket here look at this
oh
my goodness this Houseboat Rental has
breakfast included and they just pack it
all up in a picnic basket and leave it
on your front porch it's awesome
chocolate cereal oh there's a chocolate
cereal this is ham and cheese rolls oh
there's a croissants
all right Daddy I I just check the book
you want me to open these for you yeah
don't think these are screw caps though
this is not too shabby
I think the boys are being attacked by
seagulls on the Roof oh there's some big
mullet down here
oh there you go
well guys it has been a lovely Sunday
morning but me and the family are
heading off to church and afterwards
we're going to drive to Gibraltar so
we're gonna go ahead and check out of
the houseboat we definitely wish we
could spend more time here at the
houseboat this has been a it's been a
fun place to stay
oh
we're running late we better put the
camera down I'll see you in a little bit
oh
there were some very nice people who
translated for us very nice but now
we're gonna drive about six and a half
hours through Portugal through Spain and
go to Gibraltar I had a much better
experience in Lisbon than I thought I
would people are really friendly there
so I'd definitely come back
you like your egg card Mama love it
oh there's like castles in Walled cities
everywhere we've already seen like three
or four of them in the last hour
welcome to Spain guys
for me and Nathan this is our third time
going to Spain
[Music]
look we have a few yeah look at that
that's cool
foreign there you go
well good morning everybody it's 6 a.m
and the sun hasn't risen yet I turned on
all the lights and nobody's stirring I
may have over scheduled us a little bit
oh we're here at the base of the Rock of
Gibraltar we got to drive about 50
minutes to Tarifa Spain to go catch a
ferry to Morocco is this one of those
days where we've bitten off more than we
could chew yes we're so tired thinking
let's do this thing
we're near the ferry terminal in Tarifa
in southern Spain
and I'm gonna try to grab some food for
the family Brianna got a bunch of egg
sandwiches and went to the ATM and the
ATM ate my debit card we had to like
bang on the Windows of the bank and some
stranger helped me and I eventually got
my credit card back now we're a little
bit late for the ferry so we got a
Hustle
I just got pulled over by the Spanish
police they've been super cool and super
friendly
but it's taking some time
we might miss our ferry so I ended up
getting a 250 euro ticket but they just
had me paid on the side of the road with
a credit card it was interesting hey
everyone we gotta run
all right
that was crazy
yeah we'll see I think that's cheese
eggs and ham there this is
my first time sailing on the
Mediterranean Sea and our first time
going to Africa so it's gonna be cool
see that that's Africa
good morning my name is
welcome to Tangier
[Music]
these are Roman and Portuguese and
British ruins and a lot of history
so are these the big cannons they use to
control the Straits of Gibraltar around
the turn of the 20th century the whole
entire Mediterranean Sea is bottlenecked
by Tangier and Gibraltar and if you
control those two points you can control
who comes and goes in the Mediterranean
Sea
so right now we're just exploring the
main street of the Medina which is kind
of where they have the shops and a lot
of people live and it's still early in
the morning so it's quiet you know just
things are just getting wound up Tangier
is all Hills all Hills so we're in the
Jewish quarter of Tangier you can see
these old houses up above there they
have the dates the initials of the
original order from 1896
so we're walking down America Street and
it's called that because Morocco was the
first country to recognize the United
States in 1776. yeah
the time that was a cemetery that was it
yeah in a pickup motorcycle we should
get one of those yeah I've never owned a
pickup truck but that's tempting right
there oh yeah
yeah those are scorpion fish they're
chubby see this is Atlantic salmon I
think that's a Whiting
limpets yeah
[Music]
yeah
oh nice
oh that smells good oh I love it the
smell of the spices in there there's
some really good food yeah stay close
[Music]
um
oh it's nice it's not too sweet it's
like lots of almonds and flour and sugar
it's
it's
nice
[Music]
excited
this is another uh
it's good no I love it
all right got some dates
okay you want to go downstairs
does that look awesome Nathan with you
in the garage
it's like I got a little Moroccan soccer
team here
[Music]
look at that right this is a public oven
you bring your stuff down you pay the
guy he cooks it for you there you go
they're hazelnuts yeah roast them
otherwise they rot
yeah what is this
there you go clean your clean your teeth
with it that's it
look at the tiles huh isn't that
gorgeous that's like they had in Lisbon
right
what do you guys think are these pretty
cool look at the gun I think maybe we
need to get a knife or something to
display at home look at these guns
be careful that's it yeah that's a
bayonet I came this close to buying a
musket this close
I shouldn't but Becca I don't need more
animal hides right
I don't have a go hide babe I don't okay
I gotta get going we basically have
World Cup they cheat you cheat
come over here
oh look at those are cool that's what it
looks like a fortnight you can put it in
your Christmas tree oh it is like a
Christmas tree
yo could Siri how little sleep we got
last night I'm doing pretty good
come on there's cats just everywhere the
boys are loving it it's lunch time and
we want to grab some Moroccan food so
we're gonna come in and quickly grab
some lunch
oh wow
look at this
this is pretty oh like is that good
bread
I like olives
oh the weather's been gorgeous it's been
laid back nothing's been crowded this
has been really nice highly recommend
coming here in November
[Music]
it's the Muslim call to prayer
you can hear the call to prayer with all
the minorites across town
thank you oh
beautiful oh wow oh look at that
I think those are dates right there in a
big chunk of lamb some eggs and that's
like some chicken couscous and cucumbers
I love lamb oh
say thank you thank you it's like fresh
squeezed mango just Blended up it is so
good with fresh out
here watch out this is the dessert
oh you guys wouldn't like this we should
just eat it for you oh honey yes oh look
at that
it's like a deep fried dough with honey
and seeds on it
oh that was good wonderful it's been
wonderful it's been wonderful what did
romance used to be okay
[Music]
okay thank you so much we had such a
great time listen if you guys are in
Morocco and you want to do this too make
sure to check out VIP Africa I'll put a
link in the video description to this
tour it's a great way to see the city
and get acclimated and it's really
affordable
comprehension about Morocco I
chill friendly City and we had such a
great time and felt so safe be real
careful
Morocco is definitely on my list of
places to go back and visit tell you
what the city of Tarifa is really cool
there are a ton of castles here man I
wouldn't mind spending more time in
Tarifa either
okay we just entered Gibraltar and it is
a tiny little territory of the United
Kingdom so tiny in fact that in order to
enter Gibraltar you have to drive across
the runway for the airport and the gates
just went down because I think they're
going to have an airplane Crossing
the runway right here
right underneath the Rocket Gibraltar
right there
yeah right on the beach this is a nice
little place
where did the soccer ball hit you
right there
have you been eating the sand
a little bit it's a gorgeous Beach
let's check out the water to see how
warm it is
if it was sunny instead of raining I
think I might go swimming
well it's been kind of a low-key
afternoon I've just been cleaning sand
off the kids and we ordered some pizza
and uh oh oh wow that's that's
very small the thing is that's a medium
like the size this is my finger there
you go there's the world's smallest
pizza right there oh long as it tastes
good and we got some leftover kebabs
[Music]
fighting is the perfect way to end the
day just hang it out in bed watching A
Goofy Movie together you guys like this
yeah yeah I'm gonna put this up I'll see
you in the morning we're gonna explore
Gibraltar a little bit tomorrow well
good morning guys we slept so long I
think I went to bed at 9 00 p.m and woke
up at 8am so good solid 11 hours and I
feel like I could do it a couple more
what a gorgeous morning
a nice little Ferrari
oh look at this the castle wall guys
you guys want to go up the Rocket
Gibraltar let's do it
yeah
and they bite you you feed them they
also bite you
all right guys
snaps will fall in colors
and we're gonna walk down
okay guys thank you thank you
come outside
that monkey just jumped on me to get
close to him oh he's eyeball in that one
yeah my great uncle Gene got his ear
bitten off by a monkey that was on his
shoulder so that's all I was thinking
about
all right guys so this right here is all
of Gibraltar you can see we're right on
Top of the Rock and there's this little
strip of land on both sides where people
live and that right there is the runway
that's the border between Spain and
Gibraltar so that's all Spain that's all
Spain that's all Spain and way over
there in the haze that's Africa
that's the beach where we played soccer
last night that's where we stayed
oh
thank you
look at the parkour
you don't like don't let the monkeys in
what kind of take the corner are you
that's fancy Europe right there that's
what that is
boys what do you say thank you you want
me to taste a little taste a little bit
here no no no no no no no I'm just Dad
taxed you like that it looks really good
I have an omelette on toast
all right we're gonna walk down the
mountain and check out some sites along
the way
little baby monkeys
yeah he's chewing on your head a little
bit he's just chewing away on your head
what
okay
thank you
look at that
because like we're not going down this
way
that is the Gibraltar Skywalk well I'm
Luke and since I went on the Skywalk
that makes me look
Skywalker the force is strong
[Music]
the guard shack up here
plus there's a jail cell over here
I hate stairs
yeah I think these are the toilets
there's a monkey
oh I see what you're about that monkey
just grabbed under my bag and tried to
rip it open I've seen him do it to a
couple people to try to get food out of
their bags
yeah 1789 to 1897.
hey look the mountain has a nipple ring
there's a whole bunch of caves here in
Gibraltar and one of them is St
Michael's cave
they call it St Michael's cave because
that giant swag type formation looks
like an angel with wings
shirt
Becca do you love family photos I do
even the Headless floating Tommy one
like the Green Jacket
I was kind of kitsy and short but you
know it came free with the package that
was kind of fun so the lady was coming
up and taking a selfie with the monkey
the Monkey Jumped over her shoulder like
Peter grabbed her cell phone
look caution rabbits
[Applause]
[Music]
five battery dude
[Music]
be slow there's small birds without legs
here
that's an old machine gun bunker
foreign
exhibit there's lots of different
exhibits things to see along this road
but we have to be very selective because
we're running out of time
gotta wear helmets during the war they
dug these out to fill them full of
supplies and men and Barracks so they
could hold out against Italy and Germany
sure why they're having us wear hard
hats
to Anderson Scotland May 11 1959.
look that goes way back there toxic
the hospital
look at these rock formations
oh this is where the kitchen was
Hudson fighter bomber oh this one's
getting low
hey Tom did you like that was that cool
yeah
means
this is an old Moorish Fort back from
when the mowers controlled this part of
the world
stood 10 sieges
these days
Too Tall too tall
there's an old fortress Courtyard
there's the wall that goes down and
there's some more gate keeps down there
check it out you got a great view of the
runway which is the border between Spain
and Gibraltar there's a plane taxing
across the road and they've cut off the
road
a pretty Cemetery
oh we made it
oh that was quite the hike
well we've had a great time in Gibraltar
but we've got to make tracks North to
the Spanish city of Seville
everybody
I believe they do holy smokes so
beautiful wow all right guys we're in
Seville Spain
[Music]
and we have rented a small Palace
oh my goodness this is huge this is huge
this is substantial
stop touching I love how there's just
like a living room in between the
bedroom and the bathroom just you know
this
um this is bedroom number four oh
yeah there's a washer and dryer you can
do the laundry while sitting on the
toilet that's awesome
folded poo people I realize we have lost
naked in here there's like a kitchen
table in between all the bedrooms
where is Nathan oh wow this is
this is huge oh this must be the kitchen
[Music]
oh geez yeah
oh it's another bathroom whoa hey guys
guys look come here do you know what
this is
this is a bidet this is for washing your
butt Oh I thought that was a urinal nope
you guys excited to wash your bottoms
yeah
another bathroom down here more bidets
bedroom number six open the door
[Music]
well it's about 5 30 so siesta's just
ended and I think it's time for us to go
out sport the city a little bit get some
dinner
I was planning on taking a taxi then I
realized there's five of us
because the Spanish take a siesta in the
afternoon they tend to stay up late and
restaurants and businesses are open late
I think we're gonna take advantage of
the Spanish nightlife and try to see the
town tonight
all right guys this is the parque Maria
de luiza those are all orange trees in
this park well Nathan
this is all like decorated tile this
whole thing apparently this is called
the El Plaza de Espana this place is
awesome it's just full of people
foreign
[Music]
stuff that we didn't even know was here
really excited to explore Seville some
more
foreign
is gelato better than ice cream yes
Nathan's the only one of my kids that's
had gelato all right guys here's here's
one for you
and uh
and you've got the creme brulee
guys you like gelato better than ice
cream
guys are you having a great time in
Seville
here hop in the back all right Becca
I'll see you back at the house be good
for Mama
and I'm gonna go ahead and walk home
just kind of see the city a little bit
all right get ready for bed buddy well
we got the kids to bed and it's just me
and Becca and our little Spanish Palace
but it's late so we're just gonna go
ahead and put up the camera and I will
see you guys in the morning
well good morning everybody me and Tom
are getting out and about before
everyone wakes up we're gonna go get
ourselves some Bakery goods and bring
them back to the family you ready to do
some hunting gathering with your dad
sir all right me and Nathan had those
last time we were in Spain
look at that I love how she wrote
wrapped that maybe get like some
croissants or something
automatic juicy machine you like that
holy smokes
or something
okay
breakfast
all right
oh that's delicious this umberical ham
is awesome it's made by taking this
special breed of pig feeding it only
acorns then taking the hind legs and
curing it in salt for a year and a half
to three years and it's just delicious
this croissant is full of Nutella no Tom
you wouldn't like it you hate Nutella
[Music]
now that we got breakfast out of the way
I think we're gonna go see Seville a
little bit we're gonna do a little
carriage ride or something
all right guys
ah taxis are so cheap here we've yet to
pay over five bucks for one yeah
hi should we go do a Horse Ride yeah
when me and Becca got married we had a
horse-drawn carriage take us to our
honeymoon suite and a lady with very few
teeth drove the carriage and played Led
Zeppelin very loudly
foreign
so this is the park we walked through
last night and it is absolutely gorgeous
South America
this is a plaza de Espana that we
checked out last night and it's really
gorgeous in the daytime
the boys are jazzed because a little bit
of Star Wars Episode 2 is filled here
the people you serve thought you did a
good job
look they got a Taco Bell we can get
authentic Mexican food
what do you think all right guys you
gotta try uh paella there
okay I know this is fast food paella but
that's kind of what we need we're
checking out in like 20 minutes so
daddy
well that was lovely but way too quick
once again another place we've got to
come back to
try a Spanish deal
yeah I like it you don't feel like
you're getting cancer when you eat him
so welcome to Portugal
do you think does this look good
[Music]
buddy
not bad
all right let's see what's upstairs
got some more beds
and more bub washers
are you guys going swimming yeah
I'm here Jacob I'll help you to swim
all right oh it is so nice to be out of
that car and just relaxing here in the
Sun
all right we're gonna go get dinner
oh that is a perfect Sunset what a
beautiful beach
this is why I love coming to the
Mediterranean over Thanksgiving break
the weather's nice and there's no crowds
okay the view is lovely oh look at that
it's a fancy hot chocolate Jake are you
putting more sugar in your hot chocolate
this is a salad we've got cheese ham
fruit veggies underneath there
ranch with Citrus in it you better go
ham and melon did you enjoy your hot
chocolate yeah but I appreciate that
well good morning it's a lovely day and
time for some breakfast
I'm gonna put some balsamic vinegar on
this
all right all right just a touch of pity
pity which is a little bit like Tabasco
sauce
thank you
ah should we have some breakfast no
that's what I'm saying
well today me and the boys are going
fishing now originally we were going to
take a charter to a hidden beach with
this awesome cave but the waves are kind
of rough today and so the captain said
we can't do that we can only go fishing
and so mom's gonna stay back with Jacob
and me and the boys are gonna go fishing
bye-bye babe
what's your name
[Music]
difficult relationship so yeah gorgeous
Beach over there Portugal has amazing
beaches and great surfing
we got some razor clams we got some
shell clams we got prawns
it is good bait anywhere in the ocean
now who's gonna catch the most fish
constantly is checking if you have any
bait
not for
eign
what are these called this one's looks
like uh
their type of bream there we go it's
going back down okay
oh there we go nope
striped bream huh
[Music]
holy mackerel it's a mackerel
micro
a little Breen but this one's a little
small to keep right it's a little small
we'll throw them back see what we got oh
I have a herd of horse mackerels see
what you got let's see what you got Tom
oh look at that
bazooku that is an excellent Name you've
caught a bazookoo a bazooka put it in
the Bazooka bucket oh
there a little horse mackerel we that
was like 10 years ago like look at that
not too shabby so uh we're gonna go
ahead and fire up the grill
tell me we're not going hungry today
ribs here and that's hello
charcoal on the beach on the ball to
easy bus all right we're gonna see the
technique here nice all right you ready
to you ready to try the bazooku
he's smiling at me
what do you think of the Bazooka
yeah it's a lot
fresh fish on a boat and a beautiful day
oh I'll take one of those thank you
it's so weird because it's pretty calm
out here in the ocean but those are big
Breakers I think those are like eight
ten feet these Cliffs are gorgeous and
there's a whole bunch of beautiful
little caves and secluded beaches that
you can see but the waves are really
rough right on the shore and so we can't
take the dinghy into the cave
oh those Cliffs are beautiful
you got this yeah oh we watch it go over
if you want to come here and fish with
cruzero de oras or do any of the things
you see in this video check the video
description below for all the links to
their websites you guys have a great day
thank you very much oh you see some
mullet
look at this look at the bullet in here
every restaurant on the streets got the
World Cup game tuned in Portugal's
playing the World Cup today
[Music]
well while we were gone apparently mom
found a secret staircase
[Music]
oh my goodness well this is pretty
Rebecca has this been a fun trip what a
great trip Happy Thanksgiving it is it
is Thanksgiving and we need to go and
find some place to go eat a very
Portuguese Thanksgiving dinner sounds
[Music]
good or you got melted cheese with honey
and nuts
babe we got a lot to be thankful for
this season don't we
oh that looks good thank you very much
look at that black pig you better go
steak not too shabby for Thanksgiving
and all the kids have ran off to go play
with neighborhood children in the little
park behind us and they are having a
ball so it's turning out to be a great
day
this has been a lovely house but it's
time to head back to Lisbon OH
today
see there we go
okay whoever's going with Mom hop in
there
[ __ ] okay
how do you like your egg tart I love it
spoken
are you hungry or do you got dinner
covered I gotta confess we're a little
tired and it feels so good to just sit
down and get some food
there you go
bacon wrapped dates I've never had this
before
that is my new favorite thing to wrap in
bacon
I think we're about to get a little
sample of Fado music here
we will die
oh excellent thank you
Tommy you like your food
and Nathan's got some chicken and I've
got some octopus
oh all right guys you all full okay yes
I think it's time to head back to the
hotel
all right all right guys we're back at
our hotel and we've got to get these
boys to bed because we're getting up at
3 A.M to catch our flight next morning
okay Tom up and down but
hey Nathan
[Music]
what do I believe what makes me feel it
to write you this song
[Music]
two hours a day five months in a year oh
I loved you too long
bye
it has been a long long day but did you
have fun yeah yeah yes
well listen guys if you had fun too make
sure to check out our Travel and
Adventure playlist we've got dozens of
travel videos both domestic and foreign
and we think you guys will love them
I'll put a link in the video description
below and don't forget to click
subscribe because we put out new videos
every Saturday morning click subscribe
nailed it